didn't you guys live together with Judd
Apatow at one time I was across the
street I did he was across the street
who got on Saturday night first
Kevin David got on at the same time yes
we did together at the same time I was
left back and he came six months later
which was an eternity for you yes yes it
was I did show up six months later but
he Schneider was the first to hit in our
cast before a lot of good it did me baby
locked me a thousand times how is it so
crazy that you all ended up on Saturday
Night Live at that same time very lucky
but him him and Spade got there first
and they were writing and feature
players and they did uh they paved the
way I remember the first week Adam was
on the show he's like I remember because
I don't think he stayed up all night
since like college you know the finals
his eyes were a little puffy and go this
is the greatest thing right yeah because
he wrote a bit John Goodman's here we
got a thing for him I remember we rode
it for ourselves and then they said you
know it's really funny we're going to
give it to the other actors what why is
that why don't we get it well because
you're writing yeah but it's funny for
us you know because I didn't even get
the concept of being well you were hired
as a writer yeah yeah when you guys are
exciting live and you have an office and
stuff like do you go there and actually
like sit there and write in your office
yeah there's so many you understand half
of a half in office that's how many
people were there right they had like an
office that was like no window and I got
the air conditioning and the heating
great so it's freezing or boiling and
we're both claustrophobic they're
torturing you but I remember we shared a
dressing room for many years and like
Adam would be asked me questions and
then just like you know should I shave
my pubes for the scene yes yes
absolutely shave away and then you know
he said I've been itching for weeks I
said one thing you shouldn't have done
that but
he was he was the first Giant on our
show we had it was been a good time yeah
Dennis Miller used to walk around gone
okay the schneid man hit and he kind of
throwing in all our
and then you know Adam's standing going
yeah he did hit it but I gotta hit it
and you know it's like pressure it's it
was naughty pressure absolutely but I'll
tell you what I do remember going to
remember Planet Hollywood on 57th Street
was a big deal for our city it's one
more time we'd go to Planet Hollywood
and get the uh chicken tenders or
whatever the hell we get and you'd go
there because you knew young people were
going to show up there when there's a
chance to be recognized that's a new
that's like being Superman you're
getting to try it all exactly but I
remember sitting and having lunch with
him and Schneider just had that on like
once or twice the copy guy and the place
went bananas and they were all attacking
Schneider and I was sitting there eating
watching this going [ __ ] big now I
remember the first time you did you were
on Saturday live and then you got
Letterman after when you were a comic
that was the big thing that I can get on
Letterman I like to do a little
impression For You Will Chamberlain
scored 100 points in one basketball game
this is the uh four other fellows on the
team would Wilt uh during a timeout
hey
I'm open man
and then the next day we were walking in
the village and everybody recognized you
yeah everybody because that was the cool
hip show when you went on Letterman did
you do stand-up or did you just stand up
you did yeah yeah it was a rock at that
time yeah I got I was I was getting
better at it were you neurotic about
that because you have to pick what five
minutes oh my God I will say this though
yeah he did wear the same outfit the
next day
you're gonna notice this exactly just in
case it was a crazy picking the material
for that I I think I just let uh the
whoever was producing the segment he
told me what what to use I don't think I
didn't have any say in anything I just
was like okay okay whatever whatever you
say all I wanted was I it was kind of
like the beginning of my career I always
thought you would like me and I always
thought I'd let him it was like man I
wanted you guys to like me and and
that's so when I was doing Letterman and
the stuff that got okay for the show I
was like oh my God I I think he's gonna
laugh at this and I think he laughed at
one of my jokes and that's what you went
home with like oh my God Letterman said
I'm good by laughing at that